the arrest of women's rights activist
Emmeline Pankhurst outside Buckingham
Palace and Emily Davison throwing
herself in front of the horses at the
King's Darby iconic images from 1913 a
struggle for women's suffrage in Europe
is just heating up in Germany activists
like Helena Langer and Clara Zetkin were
a driving force to get the vote women
had been banned from even attending
political gatherings until 1908 from
1914 external factors shaped the role of
women in society the First World War had
begun many say that women's contribution
to the war effort back home helped
secure them the vote in 1918 in Britain
and in Germany after the Revolution
women thronged to the streets to vote
for the first time in elections to the
Viman a tional assembly in January 1919
late comers to the table of women's
suffrage were Spain in 1931 France in
1944 and Italy in 1945 and in Portugal
women were barred from voting in
national politics until as recently as
1976 and although it's not uncommon to
see women at the helm in European
politics today take a wider view and
you'll see the struggle for total
equality is still far from over
[Music]
mr. Bali 100 years of women's suffrage
how difficult is it still for women in
politics today it is still not as easy
for women in politics as it is for men
because it is still we still have to do
better as in society as a whole I guess
and we are confronted with more with
more prejudices and then men are
concerning looks concerning the way we
speak concerning our voices and yeah
it's more difficult of course
so which factors would have to change to
enable women to play a greater role it
has to become just a normal thing that
women lead as well in politics as in
economics as everywhere else so it's a
matter of development and as politicians
we have to do everything we can do to
enforce that now what would you tell
women what do they have to do
differently to play a greater role well
first of all women should as anyone have
looked at who they vote for
so women voting for women I think first
of all is not a bad idea but of course
it not every woman is a feminist and not
every woman supports women's women's
rights
well women's rights but especially
women's interests so have a look at who
you vote for and maybe be be engaged in
politics yourself it's it's an
interesting way of really designing the
world around you now there's a lot of
talk at the moment about Western
democracies being under pressure what
would you see as the greatest challenge
right now we do see that human rights
democracy the rule of law is under
pressure within Europe but also
throughout the world and women's rights
play a particular role there because we
see that in every country where you have
this this shift backwards in
well yeah fundamental rights it's always
against women that it is that it is
directed to so you have the independent
justice that is under pressure the Free
Press culture often and it's always
against women's rights because a lot of
these old men sorry to say feel
threatened by strong women and to have
strong women in politics usually means
that that at society is more open to to
any sort of human being so that everyone
has the possibility to to become what he
or she wants to be well I'm here to talk
about that struggle for equality I'm
joined by Nicola bear she's general
secretary of the Liberal Free Democrats
here in Germany let's start talking
about the representation of women in
your party in the German parliament the
Bundestag I understand you have less
than a quarter of your representatives
who are women in the parliament in
general that's around a third you've
told me why is it so low in your party I
mean we want to go to be better so we
really hard working on it we had
interviews with all the women in our
party to see what are the obstacles to
give them more time more possibility to
be engaged in politics but what I find
fin I find that it's really good is that
from the women we have in Parliament we
have over the average in important
positions for example 2/3 of the heads
of committees we have female colleagues
of mine and so it's even really
important committees as a committee of
Finance Committee of Human Rights new
colleagues first time period in
Parliament but at the party leader and
the borough of the party are very
interested in having role models in
having good colleagues the chance to
have important position I think this can
help okay now your party understands is
launched a task force on diversity
management it focused
is mainly on trying to get more women in
the party and putting them in positions
that you were just describing what's
your strategy there the strategy is
first to hear what the women really want
what is helping them how we can change
the structure of the work of the
discussion in the party and after for
what I think it's especially a question
of sensitivity in the lower regions of
the party organization because on the
top level and in the federal level there
is enough sensitivity there we really
get the women through an important
position but we have it from the bottom
on where the first contact is to women
to give them really the the feeling and
really the opportunity that they wanted
we want their competence we want their
creativity we want the other looking on
the topics we deal with and this is the
work we do now with this task force you
know this is a challenge getting more
women involved in in party politics is a
challenge not just for your party but
for lots of parties there's often talk
about imposing quotas to raise the
number what do you think of that idea of
quotas for candidates standing for
elections we have quite open discussion
in the moment for about that quota topic
but it it's really difficult because a
lot of the women things this is not the
reason why I want to get in a certain
position I am competent enough I have
really something to say I have really
something to contribute I don't want
that at the end the man can say oh it's
only because of the crota and this is a
reason why we are talking about another
way of having more women by a sort of
treaty in the organization to have
certain aims of growing the number of
women in an important position and maybe
this could be the way which is more
appropriate also to a free democratic
thinking free democratic lifestyle
Misbah
thank you so much for talking with us so
it was Nicola Bosch he is general
secretary of germ
he's a free democratic party the
Liberals thanks again